the commander-in-chief the Honorable dr.
J Trump
[Applause]
well thank you very much that's a great
honor great people thank you
sit down please thank you and I want to
thank commander Riley truly thrilled to
be here with thousands of America's
proudest and toughest and most
extraordinary Patriots the incredible
veterans of events thank you very much
we're special people you fought
courageously for our country and now my
administration is fighting courageously
for you that's for sure and you know
we've we've accomplished a lot we've
done a lot and one of the things we have
done is you get that medical care
quickly now when you go into those
doctors and you used to have to wait for
weeks and weeks and weeks and you don't
wait anymore you go out and see a
private doctor we pay the bill and
people are really happy about it and the
vets are very happy about
veterans choices you've been trying to
get that for 44 years they said a 44
years I guess it's longer than that
probably earlier than that but for 44
years at least that we know of and you
got it
so congratulations hopefully you don't
have to use it too often because you're
gonna feel great okay
every veteran here today at all across
our land thank you for your noble and
incredible service it's an honor really
of my life I understand that I'm the
first commander-in-chief first president
to address you and be here and that's
[Music]
[Applause]
and it's also an honor to be the
commander-in-chief of the greatest
fighting force the world has ever known
the United States military and it's a
lot stronger today that it wants two and
a half years ago I can tell you that
rock star a lot stronger seven hundred
billion dollars we spent and then seven
hundred and sixteen billion that's with
the be and this year at seven hundred
and thirty eight billion dollars so
we've rebuilt your military and it's
stronger than ever before and that was
really needed it was depleted it was
tired it was exhausted and you know that
better than I do
we've totally rebuilt it I want to thank
your outstanding national commander Reed
Riley as well as your terrific executive
director Joe Shanley where's Joe Joe
thank you where's Joe thank you Joe
it's not a very good seat for you Joe
give that mention right up top and look
see you want to give other people the
better seats I like that type of person
thank you Joe
it's also my privilege to recognize your
national first vice commander the
highest ranking woman in M FETs history
retired Air Force senior master sergeant
Jen Brown thank you Jim congratulations
as well to this year's recipients of the
silver helmet awards especially a dear
friend who is an inspiration to all
Americans World War two veteran and
Medal of Honor recipient woody Williams
Thank You woody looking good woody that
was a big day Medal of Honor nothing
like the Medal of Honor I wanted one but
they told me I don't qualify
they say can I give it to myself anyway
they said I don't think that's a good
idea great great people these a great
great men and women that get the
Congressional Medal of Honor Thank You
woody we are unbelievably grateful to
all of the members of ambit's Ladies
Auxiliary they've worked so hard and the
sons of AMVETS and the junior-m vets and
of course the legendary
invents writers who are fighting to keep
alive the spirit of Rolling Thunder I
love rolling
Rolling Thunder would taken care of
Rolling Thunder since I've been there
Rolling Thunder please stand up you have
so many great people there's so many
great people thank you thank you when
the leaders are all here to thank you
and we'll see you in a little while in
Washington and to honor the prisoners of
war and those missing in action today we
renew our vows that America will never
ever forget it's a great thank you great
to be joined by a number of champions
for Americans veterans including
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos Betsy
that's a great job
deputy VA secretary James Byrne James
thank you great job a man who has really
done a great job I don't know if he's
appreciated sometimes it doesn't work
out that way but he's done an incredible
job and your state is doing phenomenal
business and I want to take all of the
credit but I can't because I have to
give him a lot too because he has been a
truly great governor Matt Bevin
Thank You Matt and you know Kentucky has
record numbers right now it's the best
year they've ever had in just about
every category so it's a really an
incredible thing and a man who I just
watched on television he's so good you
can do television for me anytime you
want congressman Thomas Massie where's
Thomas
good job Thomas say hello to our friends
say hello to our friends back in
Washington that was a good job just
watched you I cannot come to Kentucky
without also praising the exceptional
work of senator Mitch McConnell I have
to tell you this guy is a true fighter
for our veterans and for Kentucky he's
worked tirelessly to enact massive tax
cuts record defense spending and crucial
VA reform that I was just talking about
and I have to think yet of all the
things with respect to Mitch Mitch is a
he's a good person but his leadership in
the Senate we've confirmed think of this
almost a hundred and fifty federal
judges to uphold our nation's beloved
Constitution and the foundation of
American freedom and Mitch and I have
worked very hard up to 150 within about
two months we'll be at 179 federal
judges and clear Supreme Court judges
it's your senator and it's for him
that's that's a passion like I've never
seen before and there is nothing more
important you know when I became
president they said the most important
thing you can do is judges and in
particular they said Supreme Court
justices as well as you know we've named
two Supreme Court justices right justice
capital justice courses and I want to
just congratulate Mitch McConnell and
you have them you have them and he's a
champion and he fights hard and he
really is something special he loves
your state and I'll be here campaigning
for Mitch and I'll be campaigning for
Matt and we're gonna get him both back
in and I just had to say because mitch
has been somebody very special and matt
does that as well this year we
commemorated the 75th anniversary of
d-day June 6 1944 when thousands of
American patriots stormed the beaches of
Normandy and charged through the fires
of hell to ensure the survival of
Liberty this year also marks the 75th
anniversary of the organization that
took care of those victorious veterans
when they returned in every generation
of veterans since incredible job today
we celebrate events for 75 years of love
and lifelong service to our military
personnel to our veterans and to their
families congratulations thank you very
much an vets posts across the nation
have become pillars of pride in our
communities so true and shining symbols
of the enduring power of the American
spirit your support of our troops
overseas it welcomes them when they come
back home and you welcome them and
you're there for them and every way
medically physically morally you're with
them all the way and they appreciate it
much more than you would even know you
safeguard our values pass on our
traditions and teach generation after
generation to love our country honor our
heroes and always respect our great
American flag
we gathered today at a truly incredible
time for our nation we are real waiting
American pride American confidence and
American greatness we are America first
[Applause]
it's about time wouldn't you say we here
America first you didn't used to here
you didn't used to here that too much
right you didn't used to hear it at all
come to think of it you hear it a lot
now hope you don't get sick of it I
don't think you will not this group not
too many people in our country would
feel that way we're respected again as a
nation for respected again we're
restoring the fundamental principles
that government and its first obligation
is the highest loyalty is to our
citizens
it's the loyal to our citizens that
really is that first obligation no
longer will we sacrifice America's
interest to any foreign power in all
things we are putting our country first
we are saying let's say make America
great again but we're almost there well
we say make America great again we may
have to switch it you know we're gonna
switch it to right that's right that's
right I won't say it here because this
is not a campaign speech
[Applause]
it's not a campaign
I will not say Keep America great but
we're gonna keep America great
it's a lot of press that's a lot of
cameras go and look at all those red
lights on there the red lights means
you're on when the lights are off you
could get a little sleepy back here and
take it easy nowhere is this patriotic
allegiance more essential than
fulfilling our duty to the American
warrior and to the American veteran
we are upholding our nation's solemn
pledge to protect those who protect us
and they protected us brilliantly with
America's core interests guiding us as
we do we are making unprecedented
strides our incredible American warriors
have pulverized the bloodthirsty killers
of Isis we defeated 100% of the
Caliphate in Syria
we're holding thousands of Isis fighters
right now prisoners and we've gotta give
them - from where they came
to Europe certain countries in Europe
they got to take them back because we
don't want to hold them kind of give
them back we're fighting for other
people and we gotta give them back
they're gonna take them they'd rather
have us hold them and let us have them
for 50 years we don't want them we don't
want them they should take them do we
agree they should
they say to us why don't you hold them
in Guantanamo Bay for 50 years and you
just sold them and spent billions and
billions of dollars holding them and I'm
saying you gotta take him we fought we
have them captured they're all captured
thousands Isis but now Europe has to
take them in different countries where
they came from have to take them do we
agree with that I'm just curious as to
what you thought we was drew from the
horrible Iran nuclear deal horrible deal
we brought home the remains of our
fallen North Korean war heroes so many
of them many more accountable so they
can rest alongside their brothers and
sisters and Americans we believe in our
sacred responsibility to ensure no one
is left behind right we're rebuilding
the awesome might of the United States
military with these big budgets that I
just described and think of it thank you
thank you very much I appreciate it
thank you very much and we're very proud
of it we're very proud of it and those
in the military very proud too beautiful
knew the best equipment in the world we
make the best planes we make the best
missiles we make the best ships we make
the best everything and also in this
case secondarily it also happens to be
made in the USA every inch of it and
it's called jobs jobs jobs that second
and the army will very soon have 300
powerful new m1 Abrams tanks the Navy is
deploying the most advanced class of
aircraft carriers in history with
hundreds of brand-new f-35 s and f-18s
American airmen will continue to own the
skies wherever we fly we have the
greatest F lesson and we're preparing to
dominate the newest war fighting domain
by establishing a sixth branch of the
Armed Forces it's called the space force
we need that the space force that's
moving along through approval and it's
become very very popular people see it
now more than they did two and a half
years ago they see it down they know how
important it is for defense and offense
and for everything we've delivered the
largest pay raise and years for every
soldier sailor Airman Coast Guardsman
and marine in the United States military
one of the largest inverses
our active-duty personnel are the best
equipped best trained most
technologically advanced fighting force
in the history of the world the best
equipment in the world best training in
the world America is a peace-loving
nation we seek friendship we see
commonly not conflict and division but
if we are threatened
we will never hesitate to defend our
people as they should be defended I have
our enemies she dared to fight us they
will be crushed with overwhelming
American might no adversary stands a
chance against the awesome power of the
red white and blue there is no military
even
you
there is nothing close and they all know
it and they tell me that they tell me
that there's nobody close and we have to
keep it that way and we don't want to
have to use it we don't want to have to
use it but we have to have it just in
case
right the members of our armed forces
hunt and you understand that very well
the members of our armed forces have
always lived by the word of Douglas
Magatha in war there is no substitute
for victory we have an Armed Forces
that's unparalleled and to achieve
victory there is no substitute for the
unmatched character and courage of those
who proudly wear the nation's uniform
and we even have different uniforms that
you see some of the different designs of
the uniforms we're going back to a style
and a look that nobody thought we'd go
back to because of expense and now we
have brand-new the most beautiful
uniforms you've ever seen but much more
importantly are the people that wear
that uniform what's inside that uniform
that's much more important that's the
best in the world every warrior who
serves has a poured out and they have
poured out their hearts and souls for
America we believe their government must
show them the same devotion in return
and we've been doing that at least in
the last two-and-a-half years we have
can you believe it's almost three years
now because I've been saying two and a
half years now for a number of months
and we're getting close to three I'll
have to be changing it to three versus
after years of neglect we're fixing the
heartbreaking failures from the last
administration at the Department of
Veterans Affairs America was never
abandoned our heroes in their hour of
need will never do that for that reason
I proudly signed into law the
groundbreaking VA Accountability Act
and that was another one they wouldn't
do it 40 years 50 years they wouldn't do
it you couldn't get it done and I won't
blame unions and I won't blame civil
service I won't blame any of it but Ben
was there power against it it was tough
but I got it done now somebody mistreats
you or mysteries people in the VA and we
know what happens right it's called your
fire
stand up please the man that implements
it you're fired get out of here get out
of here you couldn't fire anyone for
virtually any reason they could do
anything so we have the accountability
act and we've removed more than 7,600
bad employees who failed to give our
vets the care they so richly deserve
7,000
think of that they were treating some of
them most of them fantastic but some of
them were treating our people our great
heroes so badly
sadistic terrible people they were
terrible people and they're gone they're
fired they would never have been 7,600 I
didn't know you were that vicious to get
rid of that Benny and everyone deserves
to be out right good that was a big deal
I was a hard one to get and as I said
and something that I guess I'm most
proud of because I don't know
accountability was very important some
people think it was as important maybe
not but most significantly the VA
reforms we did the veterans choice and
that's I don't know which was more
difficult they were pretty much equal
but since I took office nearly three
million veterans have been able to
choose a private doctor in their own
community and have you ever seen and
this is a great tribute to the people at
the VA the people and the leadership of
the VA I don't hear these horror stories
you know I used to see it's growing up
but see va va va I don't want to you
know well let me find some wood way I'm
not hearing bad stories I'm hearing all
good stories but the fake news will go
out they'll find somebody in the system
find somebody they'll find somebody in
this giant medical system the largest
system in the world by far they're going
to find somebody that wasn't treated
perfectly and he'll be on the top of the
news tonight we have breaking news we've
also slashed wait times at the VA by
more than 33 percent that's a great
thing and the care is better more
importantly the cameras even better
a recent study published in the Journal
of American Medical Association found
that wait times are now shorter for
primary care at the VA that had private
sector doctors and hospitals say hello
to a friend tell him he's doing a good
job he's done some job what a job all of
you have done to improve the efficiency
of the VA I signed the veterans appeals
improvement and Modernization Act you
know that is so far this fiscal year the
VA has processed nearly 1.2 million
claims for compensation and increased
the number of Appeals decisions by 70
percent compared to two years ago when I
really started doing this that's a big
number
we are modernizing your medical records
to begin a seamless transition from the
Department of Defense into the VA
something that they just said they
couldn't do you know that right they
said we can't do it it's just too
complicated we did it the VA has also
cut opioid prescriptions by 30 percent
over the last tour to half
and we're committed to defeating the
opioid epidemic in America and I've
instructed all of our people that give
so many grants to lots of geniuses all
over the country I said find a
painkiller
that's non-addictive get a painkiller
that when you break your arm and you go
to the hospital you don't come out of a
hospital addicted to opioids get a
painkiller
that's not addictive and we're closer
than you think
right we're closer our veterans are
seeing dramatic improvements in the
quality of care across the board
patients trusts have increased I mean
you look at the trust that the patient's
give increase that 92% of VA Medical
Center's 92 percent increase at the
medical centers and we will not rest
until we reach 100 percent and we'll get
there - well bathroom probably there
already probably were there already no
issue facing our veterans is more urgent
than ending the national crisis of
veterans suicide my administration
he's determined to do everything in our
power to save the lives of our heroes
and if you think about what's going on
we have a new I guess you'd call it a
drug that came out Johnson and Johnson
and I know you're dealing very strongly
with them I think they should make a
contribution to the United States of
America but they have something that
whatever it may do it really takes that
horrible anxiety whatever causes
somebody to be so desperate to commit
suicide you take it it's an inhaler and
you take it and it's results are
incredible
I don't know long term but it really it
really has an incredible effect on a lot
of people and I've instructed the top
officials to go out and get as much of
it as you can from Johnson and Johnson
and I think they should make you they've
done so well in this country and they've
made so much money
I think they should give it to us for
free give it a shot
give it a shot now but it's incredible
actually it's does something something
pretty amazing it's new and it's had a
tremendous and it's been approved I
guess it's been fully approved right
it's gone through the process and it's
gone through a long process that's been
fully approved we think that's gonna
have a great impact we've secured a
record eight point six billion dollars
for mental health services and we open
it's a record
we opened the White House via a hotline
to help ensure no claim ever again falls
through the cracks I mean a lot of
claims were having a lot of problems
going on for years we work it out the VA
is now providing same-day emergency
mental health care and mental health
screenings to every patient that walks
through the door it's incredible the
difference between now and three years
ago to end the tragedy of veteran
suicide it will require government and
society at all levels working together
we have to work together with a lot of
different groups a lot of people and a
lot of progress is being made but going
to be made things are happening we must
strive to build communities that truly
serve support and protect our veterans
from the very first moment they return
to civilian life
it's an incredible adjustment that's
exactly what we aim to achieve with the
prevents initiative you know what the
prevents initiative is a task force
created earlier this year to unify the
efforts of government business and
nonprofit groups we want to build on
proven strategies like the EM vets heal
you know and that's healed you know what
it is talking about program an amazing
partnership with the VA that has served
over 600 families in crisis in just the
last year without a single life lost to
suicide not one for every veteran who is
facing this struggle I want you to know
that you are not alone we are with you
you are not forgotten not at all for God
we're with you all the way and you are
not beaten you will overcome you will
prevail you will triumph and you will
thrive you will thrive a lot of progress
has been made so many different things
we're making progress in millions of
Americans are right by your side and we
are with you every single step of the
way one of those Americas is Americans
as someone that you know very well Jim
pigeon a Navy veteran and former
national commander of AMVETS Jim wisdom
come on up here come on up here Jim for
the past one thousand two hundred and
fifty seven consecutive days Jim has
challenged Americans to join him in
doing 22 push-ups don't challenge me
don't make me do that
representing the number of veterans
whose lives you need to think of that
twenty two representing that's the
number of suicides a day can you believe
I heard that number and I said can't be
possible you would think a year a month
a day nobody can believe it nobody
believes that Jim thousands of Patriots
have joined him in raising awareness and
together they are summoning the National
will to act and I want to thank Jim Jim
say a few words please
Thank You mr. president is what honor to
be here I would not be able to do this
without the support the love and the
prayers of my beautiful wife Paulette
get strong arms just tap them it's like
a piece of steel thank you Jim no one
deserves the blessings afraid of more
than the heroes who risk their lives to
defend it for this reason my
administration has worked aggressively
to boost veterans employment and we're
setting records since my election we
have reduced the number of unemployed
veterans by 37 percent as veterans
unemployment has reached the lowest
level ever recorded you ever hear that
that's big
same thing with african-american
unemployment same thing with Asian
unemployment same thing with Hispanic
unemployment same thing with many other
groups it's been amazing to every
employer in America we say if you are
looking for a worker of unrivaled skill
integrity and devotion all you have to
do is hire a veteran that's what's
happening and they're doing
I have a friend who's been doing it
lately and he said why didn't I do this
25 years ago I said that's your problem
he's very happy every service member is
the right to return to civilian life
with dignity and security and that's
what's happening driven by this core
principle we have helped 30,000 veterans
find permanent housing over the last two
years 30,000 we have also expanded the
GI Bill so that veterans can use their
benefits to get an education than any
point of their lifetime a crucial reform
to expand opportunity to veterans in
every stage of their career that's a big
thing and today I'm proud to announce
that I am taking executive action to
ensure that our wounded warriors are not
saddled with mountains of student debt
in a few moments I will sign a
memorandum directing the Department of
Education to eliminate every penny of
federal student loan debt owed by
American veterans who are completely and
permanently disabled
credible
nobody can complain about that right
nobody can complain about that the dead
of these disabled veterans will be
entirely erased it'll be gone then you
sleep well tonight all together this
action will wipe out an average of
$30,000 in debt owed by more than 25,000
eligible veterans who have made immense
sacrifices the ultimate sacrifice in
many in many ways for our nation they've
made a sacrifice that's so great and
there's such incredible people and they
never complained they never complain
that's hundreds of millions of dollars
in student debt held by our severely
wounded warriors it's gone forever I
want to thank secretary DeVos for her
leadership and making veterans that
forgiveness a top priority for the
Department of Education Betsy thank you
very much stand up
and there will be no federal income tax
on the forgiving debts so that's really
big stuff so I'll pass it's all past all
we have to do is sign it which we're
going to do right at that beautiful desk
[Applause]
today I'm also calling upon all 50
states to immediately waive all
applicable state taxes as well the state
taxes hopefully will be going away very
quickly most of the states have already
agreed to do their joining us today is
one of the many American heroes who will
benefit from this action Katherine
castle amazingly Katherine served in
three different branches of the armed
forces the army the Navy and the Air
Force Wow you're gonna have to tell me
which is the best please I want to know
which is the best
[Applause]
which is the best so don't say don't say
it I might as you may say it now be in
big trouble
thank you everybody this is an amazing
relief on my family as well as I know
many thousands of veterans as well thank
you
thank you very much after two tours in
Iraq Katherine developed multiple
serious health conditions very very
serious related to her service including
significant lung problems despite these
obstacles Karin is now pursuing a degree
at the University of Nevada Catherine we
are really profoundly grateful for your
service and for your men sacrifice
you've been incredible and thank you and
it's great to have gotten to know you
and everybody in this room is very proud
of you thank you very much thank you
Catherine
veterans like Catherine who have made
such enormous sacrifices for our country
should not be asked to pay any more
rather it is America who owes our heros
a supreme debt of gratitude so that's
the way we feel across our shoes jungles
mountains and deserts and battlefields
and enemy camps across the globe our
veterans fought and bled to vanquish our
enemies and preserve America's
birthright of freedom our country our
Liberty our families our homes our
safety our very lives everything that
matters and everyone who we hold dear
our sacred and just sacred to us and
secured by the grace of God and the
immortal courage of those who serve the
story of the American veteran and I
called the American warrior because
that's what they are the great warriors
is the story of the American nation you
have written our history shaped our
identity forged our destiny March
gesture glory and always planted the
righteous flag of American victory
you have filled our enemies with dread
you have filled our friends with hope
and you have filled our American heart
with fierce patriotic pride because of
You America is safe because of you
America is strong because of you America
is free and because of you
America will forever remain the bravest
mightiest and greatest nation on the
face of the earth thank you because of
you I would now like to ask em vets
leaders to come forward
secretary DeVos please come forward
deputy secretary burn governor Bevin
sergeant Katherine castle and Sergeant
Nick Staffan ik2 join me on stage as I
signed the presidential memorandum
facilitating the cancellation of student
loan debt for 25,000 of our most
severely disabled veterans
and with today's order we express the
everlasting love and loyalty of a truly
grateful nation god bless our veterans
and God bless america thank you very
much thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]